nous avons été amenés à demander le
confinement des personnes âgées en ehpad
et parfois même le confinement en
chambre en nous fondant sur l'évolution
des sociétés savantes et sur l'avis
éclairé du conseil consultatif national
d'éthique et nous avons été obligés et
ça a été très dur à interdire tout droit
de visite auprès des personnes âgées
dans les ehpad tandis que le confinement
est amenée à durer encore pour plusieurs
semaines
il nous a semblé utile de consulter à
nouveau les sociétés savantes les
représentants des organismes de ces
établissements pour personnes âgées et
nous avons élaboré ensemble des
recommandations nouvelles qui
permettront à partir de demain
d'organiser dans les territoires sous la
responsabilité des directions
d'établissement un droit de visite pour
les familles à direction direction de
leurs aînés fragile admis en ehpad
ce serait à la demande du résident ce
sera dans des conditions extrêmement
vous l'imaginez limitez pas plus de deux
personnes de la famille à tout le monde
en même temps ce sera sous la
responsabilité des directions encore une
fois d'établissement qui devront dire à
la famille lorsque ce sera possible et
dans quelles conditions
sachant que la sécurité sanitaire reste
au coeur de notre projet et qu'il y aura
donc l'impossibilité maintenu d'aller
toucher la personne d'être en contact
physique par contre il y aura un contact
visuel on peut passer beaucoup de choses
avec le regard auprès des personnes
qu'on aime et j'imagine le soulagement
qui sera celui des nombreux et dans des
nombreuses familles quand ils pourront à
nouveau rendre visite à leurs proches
souvent des personnes en perte
d'autonomie parfois désorientés mais qui
savent très bien ce que c'est que la
valeur d'un regard d'une personne
aimante
notre objectif c'est toujours de trouver
un équilibre entre sécurité et maintient
vital du lien social comme dans tous les
aspects de cette crise nous appelons
chacun à la plus grande des
responsabilités et au respect des
consignes précises qui seront données
par les professionnels j'ajoute enfin et
c'est normal que ce droit de visite très
encadrée pourra s'appliquer dans les
mêmes conditions
pour les établissements qui accueillent
cette fois ci des personnes en situation
de handicap et je m'en suis entretenu
avec la secrétaire d'état
sophie cluzel il a les personnes qui se